the new Dancing with the Stars path just
revealed today Derek Hough said he
wasn't coming back guess what he's back
what did it take to get Derek HOF back
on the show it logistically worked out
his desire was to be on the show but he
couldn't very well pass up that
opportunity to do the show at Radio City
if just everything kind of aligned for
him to be able to do both I'm sure the
other pros are hoping the jet lag gets
to him
Derek's on Broadway performing with the
Rockettes he's paired with Olympian
Nastia Liukin they'll compete for the
10th anniversary' gold mirror ball how
does that feel the hold mirror ball
trophy I feel like a champion what are
you gonna do next I'm gonna join the
next season and win Dancing is banking
on a tried and true formula we'll have
to see if it works again one of the main
ingredients 70 superstar Suzanne Somers
how skimpy will you go with the outfits
I've never been terribly conservative in
my dressing to the point where my
children don't watch going
there's the inspiration Noah Galloway a
combat veteran and double amputee you're
hoping to inspire people by being in the
show I do I hope so I told Shana that
I'm gonna take this very serious
basically what I lack in limbs I'm gonna
make up for determination and and hard
work the diva this year it's Patti
LaBelle the athlete Michael Sam and then
there's the body Charlotte McKinney
who went nearly naked for Carl's jr. I
always a bit of movement to me